in level 30 alter das ist schon heftig
weiß nach ersten folge hast du gesagt
dein ziel ist es erstmal der max level
zu kriegen ja hast du geschafft
ich weiß und dann wollte irgendwas in
kärnten er soll jetzt dahin gehen in die
seile diamant noch keine diamanten ja
erst kommen
ich habe ein bogen uns alles und lager
im dienste sachen lehrerin gema ich
sogar meine ganzen sachen hier ein
ja ich mache auch dass gerade so ein
bisschen aber auch ein bisschen los so
er wenn die schiffbrücke der nächste
himmel bei mir anders die leute mit
meiner aufnahme schaut euch das mal
hinten was sie warum lernen so essen
nämlich auch mit natürlich stellen wir
ja das wäre schon kannst du ein bisschen
mehr gemüse verbringen dann will ich
noch 86 mit ok 86 er springt 86 ja dann
nehme ich diese mit dankeschön
dann brauche ich auch das fleisch nicht
essen falls jetzt bis jetzt irgendwie
ihnen erst ich glaube ich einfach kein
fleisch gegessen im ganzen netz player
aber falls dann entschuldigen später ich
werde ab jetzt in meiner version werde
ich vegan leben ich will dieses botnet
da weg haben wenn ich irgendwo auf einer
sache drauf bin und so das camp reduce
bla bla bla bla bla hier
grillfleisch hey ich hab das fleisch bin
dieses thema die altersabteilung
reingesteckt weg ok egal ist das
ausgemacht
also nochmals aus da kann man dann
rezepte sehen hier aber ja egal nicht
vergleich wirklich verbauen die die
steine vanni gebraten die fleisch der
benachbarten vielleicht schon probleme
dann mit gegangen was ist wenn flyer
reich hier was ist für steiner
die sieht so schön aus das sind 24
stones in den quadraten stein ziegel so
wir sind noch mal so richtig kräftig rot
die steinzeit sind ja so richtig schön
stein farben
okay ich habe keine rüstung aber
vielleicht sind wir drin was aber am
eisenstädter hab ich hab eine komplette
ausrüstung ein schwert und alles auf 30
level deswegen bin ich ein bisschen
vorsichtig vor allem war doch sehr sehr
sehr sehr viele mox waren es war schon
richtig ab da drin steht einfach mal
sagen auf gehst vor und ich schnappe die
hinterher auf nach narnia der scania
kommen direkt vom bist du hast etwas
explodiert was im alter erst letztens
bonn erwarte ich bei warsteiner was
kommt bevor wir jetzt die weiterhin ich
würde sagen in der nächsten folge
seht ihr dann in der nächsten folge seht
ihr dann wie wir hier in dieser insel
dungeon hier wie man sieht gibt es hier
geht's richtig ab
ein kind schon bei 15 minuten soviel
falschen bei blut minuten also bei mir
geht es am nächsten folge weiter ich
weiß nicht ich weiß ich hab ich das
irgendwie anders karte müssen wir
schauen also ich kann auf jeden fall ich
muss ganz kurz mein fraps ändern ist
nämlich mein bildschirm auf weil ich
eben nämlich noch etwas anders
aufgenommen habe also bei mir ist ganz
kurz aufnahmestopp und in der nächsten
folge seht ihr dann wie wir da reingehen
so wartet ganz kurz ich muss krebs
ebenso schlimm dass wir weiterhin auf so
weiterlaufen lassen
ich hab's eingestellt monitor aero
desktop so ach so er ist natürlich blöd
ja ich hab euch das 10.000 special da
habe ich
brennpunkt ort aufgenommen habe ich ganz
vergessen wir uns stellen folge eins und
zwei ponys sekunden geht es aber nicht
bereit eine fackel auf den ersten
gesetzt
da kann ich aber auch schon das erste
skelett an ok startet wieder ich habs
jetzt in die gruppe geschubst oder sind
echt viele webseiten drin sprung wieder
ins ghetto gott ich werde dich lange
schüssen angesprochen
kommst du bitte so ok wieder ja ich
musste meinen flaps ernannt und da
geht's auch schon los kontrakt hat schon
viele im körper stecken ja ich würde
sagen dass sonst an jeder seite ist ja
sonst bornum wir haben uns ja irgendwie
an jeder seite münchen aber den haben
uns immer den seitens runter was mache
ich erstmal machen die kapuzen wir die
finder monster falle leben er ich mache
jetzt einmal um fackeln darauf erstmal
das eine gute idee
da kommt video verkaufen wies der rente
wie so ein glueck luther oder zwar sind
zum wieder richtig richtig schnell
gerannt ist erstmal die skeptiker unten
drin sind
einer dessen skeletten zombie im skelett
kopf ich hier unter uns zu sowieso ein
berserker dass auch diamanten müssen das
erstmal sondern erstmal das imk ist lass
mir leid was da drin ist und anpassen
reisen sagte eine bronze displayed komme
ich habe ein pferd ich hab jetzt alles
mit kniffen einfach so entwickelt es
danach selber aufteilen er aufgegeben
vielleicht auf den andere kiste ich
meine clique ist mit und einem
touristischen blick ist dass wir mit den
zwei neu ausgeleuchtet sein wie gut das
war gar nicht so schwer wie ich dachte
ja wir müssen uns ja auf jeden fall ein
bisschen auszurichten
das war so eine kleine wodurch sich doch
das was schon mal die amazonen die
hamann saft und eintraten weil noch
einige diamant schwert oder landeten für
einen entspannten table ist natürlich
gut für alle wir daher müsse auch
zusammen also ich hab's gefunden
zusammen bewältigt hier und jetzt halt
immer gleich wir gehen an die stadt
damit oder in ein haus bremen hin
ich glaube jetzt sagen die monster und
handelns häuschen zwischen beiden
häusern okay finde ich sehr geil wo wir
gemeinsam wollten zusammen legen genau
wo gemeinsam kisten sind wo wir uns in
sachen immer tauschen wo ich solche
fleisch heilige thomas und so genau da
müssen wir schauen wie wir die
handelshäuser bauen
irgendwie ich dachte jetzt so hier
obwohl ich bin ich mal meine familie da
müssen wir schauen wie das so läuft ich
lage erst mal die sachen hier in der
extrakt ich hab noch getrickst dabei was
liegt immer hier einmal sehen was alles
alles alles dabei das hat jetzt das
verhalten etwa das
ich habe noch keine rückt und gruppen ab
diesem moment den habe ich gewartet das
wollen so zack zack zack guckt die
branche schätzt besser ist es deine die
just an wenn ihr nicht besser ist an dem
ich will die taxis besser dies besser ja
dann kannst du kannst die eisenbahn und
linke sehen noch fast frisch also bronze
ist das beste was ich dass das ein traum
von mir wenn du die branche rüstung
bekommen was dadurch an die
bronzeplastik brüstung andere ist noch
eine brüstung drin ja damals 2 ihr habt
dann kann ich mir meine reisen links
zurück
bitteschön dann kriegt aber auch die
reisebranche victoria max theurer ist
die branche axt dann nämlich ganz okay
etwa damit jetzt mal ein baum ab einfach
und sicher wieder so ist tommy um axt
okay machen weil du schon so viel eisen
8 dann kräftig geholfen haben ist
ungefähr so wie eisen packs kopfkissen
schönert hat aber keine richtige
texturen aber vielleicht vielleicht hast
du hast du da mit bestimmte ärzte von
kannst du alles abbauen kann
das weißt du nicht als mit 1 markt
genommen und das eisen dann kannst du es
gold haben den diamanten die angst vor
abzocke
was kann ich habe das was da drin ist
das ganze gold mit diamant und jetzt
markt und die 80
weil ich mir für deine franke gut gut
gut eine erfolgreiche höhen expedition
sollte zwar nicht so lange aber naja wir
wollen nicht meckern weil er gute sachen
drin war so jetzt muss ich ganz kurz
gucken sich das erweiterbare das noch
stein auch aber auf jeden fall noch
kohle da
4000 eu das will ich nicht haben
ob das licht mode mode ja wo ist der
botanische ausstellen reset mode
sag mal bitte wo man den raum stellte
drücken ja dann options und dann links
dann die plugins options plugins etwas
mal wussten wo ist eine options edano
drücken aber dann oder ja und jetzt
unten links mit options links viel tempo
denn genau im moment im sub setzen
nee da unten links steht bach und links
lara okay und jetzt steht mode wer jetzt
die plugins soll er doch da dadurch
entlastet haben ihr rezept modus
automatisch drin als können uns keine
alten versehentlich rausnehmen das heißt
was heißt reset mode dass wir immer wir
sehen immer die rezepte wird auf den
alten drauf drücken also jetzt ins
emmental ist und dann sehen wir überall
mit rezepten wir nehmen's nichts heraus
versehentlich city.de draufgehen
ich hab hier kritik etwas anders
eingestellt moment kriegst du schon hin
warum machst du da habe ich den jetzt
wieder umgestellt
es ist nacht das rennen gehen okay ich
bin im bett hauptsache ich darf die
ganze zeit ohne tür hier könnt ihr seid
monster zu bekommen ist noch keiner
passiert was heißt eigentlich recipe
mode ach du liebst licher bednarski
modells rezept modus heißt ich lege mich
jetzt ins bett
jetzt gerade ich bin halt auf dem weg in
fünf sekunden ich im bett firmen 4 4 2 2
ich habe erst mal getrunken haben noch
gar nicht gehört das gerät zwar richtig
findet sind also was wenn jetzt red i
mode
moment rexhepi mode ist dass du im
turnus modus nicht automatisch
auszusehen sondern immer die rezepte
angezeigt bekommst portal froh wenn ich
darauf dass es einfach nur zu dumm dass
ein okay okay danke liebe freunde ihr
seid echt nett darauf hat die community
haye und wenn ihr diesem video
so lasse ich jetzt da hinten mein haus
weiterbauen
erstmal will ich noch steinofen gebacken
drauf
die option helligkeit helligkeit habe
ich auf düster bei mir habe ich die
leute beschwert und gespielt ist alles
dunkel bei dir warum macht sich auf hell
und habe sogar fällt aber auch düster
ich hab's ja 50 prozent ich finde ein
bisschen dunkel muss minecraft immer
noch sein
es kostet ja ich finde es uns dass kein
treffens total hält es eine nacht muss
dunkel sein da ich habe davon ab und
helligkeit aber auch nur weil ich habe
so einen zwar der dunkelheit